l'abe de fin pour vincent bolloré
qu'attend 17 février 2022 avec beaucoup
d'impatience je vous assure j'ai une
application avec le voyez dans 2000 225
jours 7 heures 4 minutes et 14 secondes
c'est la quille et c'est là que
l'industriel breton prend sa retraite la
fin peut-être d'une longue carrière au
sein de l'entreprise familiale commencée
il ya plus de 40 ans
au début des années 80 ça va mal pour
l'entreprise familiale bretonne
spécialisée dans le papier vincent
bolloré la rachète pour un franc
symbolique au banquier edmond de
rothschild le jeune trentenaire à une
nouvelle stratégie le papier c'est fini
le futur c'est le plastique voilà ça
c'est le film de plastique on fabrique
il est dix fois plus fin qu'une feuille
de papier à cigarette les grands
chimistes mondiaux ont essayé de le
faire ils ont raté non l'a réussi c'est
le point de départ de l'air bolloré
l'homme d'affaires se diversifie et
rachète des entreprises moribondes il
s'exporte aussi en afrique dans les
secteurs ferroviaires et portuaires son
appétit et sans limites est absolument
tout semble lui réussir vincent bolloré
élu manager de l'année par
l'hebdomadaire le nouvel économiste en
1987 à 35 ans le voilà désigné manager
de l'année le petit prince du cash flow
c'est son surnom reçoit son diplôme des
mains de jacques chirac alors premier
ministre c'est ce tempérament qui est
fait de vous aujourd'hui le manager de
l'année c'est des jeunes comme vous
change aucun doute qu'ils font et feront
la france 2 2 et ça continue vincent
bolloré est insatiable et continue
d'investir dans des entreprises
acquièrent une partie du capital de
bouygues construction en 1998 bref son
empire s'étend un peu plus chaque jour
nous ne souhaitons pas avoir tous nos
oeufs dans le même panier et avoir
différents actifs nous pensons que c'est
plus sûr mais dans chacune de ces
diversifications nous n'allons que si
nous avons une position de leadership
européen ou mondial à partir des années
2000 vincent bolloré se lance dans les
médias il lance d'abord la chaîne de
télé direct 8 en 2005 déjà propriétaire
de la sfp vincent bolloré a décidé
d'investir 30 millions d'euros par an
pour des programmes entièrement réalisée
en direct puis un journal gratuit en
2007 matin plus qui deviendra ensuite c
with en 2015 le milliardaire prend la
tête de canal+ il réorganise la chaîne
de télé supprime les guignols de l'info
en plus d'être un personnage ambitieux
vincent bolloré est aussi un chef
d'entreprise clivant et redouté
actuellement il passe pour le
croquemitaine on a un peu l'impression
que
certains parents disent 'si tu t'endors
pas très vite devait aller chercher
vincent bolloré ce jeudi l'industriel
prend donc sa retraite jour du
bicentenaire de l'entreprise familiale
[Musique]